[Funny Music]
O'Neill: StoryToys is a company
Design and publish the content of children's applications.
We do a large number of activities including original IP content,
He wrote classic anecdotes,
Licensed content and much more.
Barrett: We are interested in combining reading experience
And provide interactive scenes.
It is a wonderful combination that combines my educational reading experience
And interaction with simple gaming style.
This does not distract the child during the reading experience
But remains interested in follow-up,
He feels part of the story.
O'Neill: One of the biggest challenges
Work in the area of ​​children's applications
You target two types of audience.
The first type is the children's audience,
But when it comes to selling an application,
The experience should be attractive to children
And be satisfactory to parents as well
In terms of providing good value
As well as educational values ​​acceptable to parents.
Thus ensuring parents' satisfaction with leaving their children
Interact with content.
Bennett: Since the launch of the Family Section
On Google Play, we've seen a radical shift in
Our Android experience.
We've seen a huge increase in earnings and downloads as well.
This makes Google Play the most important channel for us,
StoryToys has benefited a lot from this store,
We are therefore happy to participate.
O'Neill: The Family section is available on the Google Play Store
An innovative, safe and reliable center
Where families can find new content.
Android has tremendous testing power
Continuous and rapid development.
It offers the best service with very little effort.
It provides experimental use on the store.
We have benefited greatly from this
As we reach a wider audience.
Bennett: The Play Store provides universal access.
As a distribution channel, it has achieved unparalleled results.
The Google Play store lets you customize prices by market.
This is a wonderful and very helpful tool.
You can also benefit from Google Play translation services,
They are effective services through which all content of an application can be translated
Very quickly.
O'Neill: The Google Play store has allowed the application of "My Very Hungry Caterpillar"
To reach huge numbers of audiences.
We have found that children generally interact with this application
For 80 to 120 minutes.
We also discovered that children were cumulative in their ability to make
More than a million butterfly
They also managed to feed the hungry butterfly
More than 1/4 million fruit fruit within the application.
Bennett: We have a great interest in the future of StoryToys
Over the next few years,
We are also particularly interested in education
And this area is full of opportunities.